[Music]
on this Monday night Britain moves on to
its third prime minister this year
what Rishi sunac will bring to 10
Downing Street I am humbled and honored
and the huge challenges he's taking on
deep disappointment reaction in obesity
indigenous Community after two police
officers who made this wrongful arrest
failed to show up for an apology
ceremony
new details about the case of two
Canadian businessmen kidnapped in the
Philippines and then killed a global
news investigation into those
responsible
and smashing success
fantastic Canada's Felix OGE aliasim
serves up another championship
global national with Donna Friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after three months of extraordinary
political chaos Britain is about to get
another new conservative prime minister
and in the end it was no contest Rishi
sunak who lost out to Liz truss in
September was the only candidate to get
enough support from Tory MPS this time
he's scheduled to meet King Charles
tomorrow and be asked to form a
government
I pledge
that I will serve you with integrity and
humility
and I will work day in day out to
deliver for the British people
he is the third Tory leader in seven
weeks and like Liz truss will take
charge of the country without going to
the electorate he's making history the
first person of color to become British
prime minister and one of the youngest
to ever take on the job the scale of the
challenge he faces Shoring up an economy
headed for recession is considerable
Eric Sorensen has our top story tonight
the moment lacked the theatrics of
another leadership fight I can confirm
that we have received one valid
combination
that one was Rishi sunak who alone had
enough support from MPS to avert a wider
conservative vote backbenchers greeted
him with relief as much as enthusiasm in
a party and Country bitterly divided we
now need stability and unity and I will
make it my utmost priority to bring our
party and our country together it will
not be easy sunak takes over with the UK
in severe economic Decline and with
little confidence in the Tory party it
has been a circus I'm afraid and what
can you say it's not it's not edifying
there should be a new leader the
dizzying spectacle of Boris Johnson's
political exit followed in a Flash by
his successor Liz truss I am resigning
has left sunac with a mess to clean up
the labor party wants an election right
away okay there is no mandate now the
conservatives are completely broken
their promises but sunak told his MPS he
won't put the party's governing majority
at risk at the worst possible time
politically he can govern for two years
calling an election would be electoral
suicide the message they want to send is
that the conservative party are now
committed to a stable and Effective
Government in a period of considerable
challenges for the UK the markets
rebounded after the news broke in
London's Financial District hoped that
sunac can steady the ship of State he's
the guy who knows the market who knows
the economy better I mean that he's a
predecessor hopefully he'll settle
things down I think he's got a very good
reputation preceding him Rishi sunak
represents a cultural breakthrough for
the nation the first British Asian first
Hindu leader his wife's wealth and tax
payments were controversial
and what's on tap for a party Riven by
infighting sunaka posed his
predecessor's tax cuts here he comes but
the first person of color to move into
10 Downing Street is itself historic the
fact that this is possible now in 2022
is a new thing in which politics that
wouldn't have been the case even 10
years ago earlier this year the Prince
of Wales met the chancellor of the
ex-chequer tomorrow they will meet again
with new titles as King Charles appoints
his first prime minister Eric Sorensen
Global News
Rishi sunac is 42 he will be the
youngest British prime minister in more
than 200 years born in the UK he's the
son of immigrants of Indian origin
educated at Oxford and Stanford he was
in business and finance before politics
he once worked for Goldman Sachs sunac
was first elected in 2015. five years
later he was appointed Chancellor or
Finance Minister he quit in July after
losing confidence in Boris Johnson's
ability to govern and he led the revolt
against Johnson and came second to Liz
trust in the conservative leadership
race in September
now to Ontario Premier Doug Ford and
Ontario's former solicitor general are
being compelled to testify at the
inquiry into the federal government's
use of the emergencies act after legal
counsel for the commission says they
declined invitations to appear
voluntarily the person giving evidence
today was the intern chief of the Ottawa
Police Force the force has been heavily
criticized for not doing enough to
control the protests last winter Steve
Bell says the lessons his Force learned
have already paid off our chief
political correspondent David Aiken has
the story
well Donna until the freedom Convoy
showed up the standard playbook for
police forces across the country
preparing to deal with demonstrations
had two objectives one protect Charter
rights to Peaceful protests and two
guarantee the safety of participants and
police
perhaps incredibly protecting a
community from the harm those protests
might do was never an explicit objective
in Ottawa Police planning but we had
never taken the view of making sure
that the community and the surrounding
areas we were as responsive to their
needs that has now changed but we need
to make sure that we bring the community
impact to the front of everything we do
because it was the area that was most
violated during this event and so
several weeks after the freedom Convoy
left
and a new Convoy dubbed Rolling Thunder
showed up in the nation's capital Steve
Bell now the interim Chief let them roll
up but then made sure they rolled right
away but we used our experience to apply
towards that intelligence and created a
deployment model that actually
ultimately did I believe prevent a
subsequent occupation to
foreign
was the invocation of the emergencies
act Justified the Ontario Provincial
Police testified last week it was not
but Bell is the second senior Ottawa
police officer to testify otherwise the
powers granted under the federal
emergency declaration were significantly
beneficial in ending the occupation Bell
set meanwhile the commission has issued
subpoenas to Ontario Premier Doug Ford
and his solicitor general at the time of
the Convoy Sylvia Jones the commission
believes both have evidence it would
like to have for its deliberations Ford
and Jones though say they will fight
that subpoena in court Donna more to
come on that David Aiken in Ottawa
thanks
well two Vancouver police officers who
handcuffed an indigenous man and his
granddaughter after they tried to open a
bank account have failed to show up at a
pre-planned apology ceremony at a BC
indigenous Community nearly three years
ago the officers were briefly suspended
and ordered to take cultural sensitivity
training for their part in the wrongful
arrests and they were ordered to
apologize that ceremony planned more
than a month ago was supposed to take
place on the helsink nation in Bella
Bella on BC's Coast more than a thousand
kilometers Northwest of Vancouver nephew
garcha is there tonight nitu do we know
why the officers didn't show up
well Donna the nation's Chief says they
still don't know why those officers
decided not to show up and they only
confirmed that they wouldn't be here
after the plane touched down here in
Bella Bella this afternoon this was
meant to be a traditional apology
ceremony those officers were expected to
attend an issue a verbal apology and
their absence here today Maxwell Johnson
says is hurtful and disrespectful
members of The Vancouver Police board
and Department arriving at the small
airport in Bella Bella BC Monday
afternoon for a big moment in a high
profile case of discrimination
they've traveled to the remote Community
which is home to Maxwell Johnson and his
granddaughter Tori Ann the pair was
wrongfully arrested outside a Vancouver
Branch after trying to open a bank
account for nearly three years they've
been awaiting an apology from the
arresting officers it has been confirmed
that they did not make their way up here
today for the apology ceremony when a
colonial institution seeks to reconcile
and and to begin reconciling
reconciliation together
it is a prerequisite that they show
respect for our customers and engage
directly with our communities when we do
a ceremony they got to be here
in order to for it to be finished
so having them not here it just it's
like a roadblock to us now Tori and was
just 12 years old when the December 2019
incident happened a bank staff member
suspected them of presenting fraudulent
indigenous status cards and called 9-1-1
according to a disciplined decision
Constable Cannon Wong and Mitchell Tong
recklessly used unnecessary Force
committed professional misconduct and
assumed fraud without sufficient
information a groundbreaking settlement
agreement announced last month includes
one hundred thousand dollars in funding
to helsink Nations restorative justice
department it would have been such an
honor to have those police officers here
to see this house and to see what we do
and how we carry on our culture Monday
ceremony is also part of the conditions
of two separate human rights complaint
settlements with the bank and police
board as this case continues to spark
National conversations on racial
profiling and changes in handcuffing
policies
now Donna at the last second the nation
turned what was meant to be an apology
ceremony into what it calls an uplifting
ceremony for Maxwell Johnson and his
granddaughter Tori Ann they say that the
Vancouver Police Department has a
responsibility to explain why those
officers didn't attend we have yet to
hear an explanation from the department
but in a statement The Vancouver Police
board says it is the respondent on the
human rights case not the individual
officers adding that it is committed to
authentic healing and Reconciliation
Donna okay and Bella Bella BC thank you
Canada's competition Bureau is launching
an investigation into the country's
grocery industry the Watchdog will
examine to what extent the concentrated
ownership in the sector is playing a
role in Rising food costs members of the
House of Commons have voted to
investigate food prices and Tackle what
it calls corporate greed in the grocery
sector last month Canadian grocery
prices Rose at the fastest Pace in more
than 40 years the board's
recommendations are not expected until
June
record-breaking early voting in a
Battleground coming up why the midterm
election in Georgia is drawing so much
attention
[Music]
American voters are just 15 days away
from midterm elections always a test of
whoever is in the White House the race
for the senate seat in Georgia has
become one of the closest this time and
most watched contests in the Country
Republican Herschel Walker has been
plagued by a string of scandals and
accusations of domestic violence as
Jackson prosco reports the country is so
divided so flooded with misinformation
that some voters seem to be willing to
overlook even the most troubling
allegations
Georgia voters are fed up and fired up I
use this method I get in I pray and I do
it
and I feel that I voted right early
voting in the state has shattered
records fueled by a senate race that is
both a dead Heat and the talk of the
entire country
you know it's which one's qualified to
do the job but either way everybody
should vote yeah in the race between
Democrat Rafael Warnock and Republican
Herschel Walker George is my family the
United States of my family Walker has
become the star attraction for all the
wrong reasons the former NFL running
back has been plagued by accusations
from his own family he has four kids
four different women wasn't in the house
raising one of them he's accused of
paying for an abortion despite
campaigning on anti-abortion views on
abortion I'm a Christian I believe in
life and exaggerating his role in law
enforcement after repeatedly flashing an
honorary sheriff's badge I voted for
Herschel I don't know that he's the
greatest person to be
in there but he's absolutely better than
Warnock Herschel Walker is a Georgia
sweetheart right he is loved by
Georgians experts warn such as American
politics in 2022 where highly partisan
voters make even the most troubled
candidates electable GOP enthusiasts
believe that he will vote the way they
want and you know support the kinds of
conservative legislation that they're
interested in the Georgia Senate race
has drawn national attention because the
winner of this single seat could
determine whether Democrats or
Republicans hold the balance of power
back in Washington the race is so close
that the winner may not be decided until
after a special runoff vote in December
thank you back at the polls Georgians
are not only divided they're frustrated
at the lack of substance in this race
people are just going to vote for the
candidate that represent their party
regardless of what they do or who they
are a worrying sign of how Party Loyalty
may be the biggest issue in a state that
could decide so much for the nation
prosco Global News Atlanta
Russia claims it has information Ukraine
is planning to detonate a so-called
dirty bomb
is one made of explosives laced with
nuclear material Russia says Ukraine is
in the final stages of developing one
but provided no evidence Ukraine and its
Western allies reject the allegation and
accuse Russia of using the rhetoric as a
pretext to escalate the war
to Chinese Intelligence Officers have
been charged in the U.S accused of
trying to obstruct a criminal
investigation into the Telecom giant
Huawei the U.S Department of Justice
alleges the pair bribed a U.S law
enforcement employee for information
about an ongoing investigation into
Huawei that informant was working as a
double agent for the FBI Huawei is the
focus of multiple investigations over
the theft of technology and violations
of international sanctions Washington
has long accused Beijing of meddling in
U.S politics and attempting to steal
intellectual property in May the
Canadian government banned the use of
Huawei equipment in this country's 5G
Networks
I had the fate of militants in the
Philippines who murdered two Canadians
[Music]
the story of what happened to two
Canadians seven years ago in the
Philippines is as sickening as it is
tragic John ridsdale and Robert Hall
were kidnapped and then killed the
businessmen were in the Philippines in
September of 2015 when they were
abducted by the militant group Abu
sayyaf and held hostage in 2016 Hall and
ridsdale were beheaded a demand for a
multi-million dollar Ransom was not paid
at the end of that year prime minister
Justin Trudeau said his failure to
secure their release was his greatest
regret Global News investigative
journalist Stuart Bell recently went to
the Philippines to investigate what
happened to those responsible for the
killings and Stewart is with me now
Stuart what did you discover
well it turns out a major Manhunt has
been underway in the Philippines for the
last couple of years the Philippine
police and army have been tracking down
those responsible and as a result there
have been really dozens of arrests
surrenders and killings and our
investigation found that almost all the
key members that were responsible for
the killing and kidnapping of these two
Canadians are either behind bars or dead
and among those caught was the beheader
himself a guy who goes by the name Ben
tattoo and where has this left Abu
sayyaf than Stewart which Canada and
other countries have designated a
terrorist organization
well abusaf has not been completely
destroyed there are still a few remnants
around but it's been so weakened uh to
the point that it's really no longer
able to do what it once did which is to
paralyze foreign governments by
kidnapping their citizens
Stuart the Canadian government still
does advise exercising a high degree of
caution when visiting the Philippines
because of crime terrorism and
kidnappings what were your impressions
being there
well we're talking here about the
southern Philippines which are far from
Manila and frankly people were surprised
when I appeared on the island of Jolo in
the South they were surprised to see a
foreigner visiting there but Filipinos
are really trying to turn the page on
this part of their history they're
trying to change their reputation as a
kidnapping Haven and really rebuild
their tourist economy in what is really
a spectacular stunning part of the world
all right Stuart Valley was recently
returned from the Philippines talking to
us from Victoria tonight Stuart thanks
more than 60 people are dead after
myanmar's military launched airstrikes
on a political Gathering the event was a
celebration for the catch in
Independence organization that's a
paramilitary group that's been fighting
for the independence of one of myanmar's
ethnic minorities in the north the
organization says the event was a
concert to commemorate the anniversary
of its founding the dead include
performers and civilians the attack
comes three days before Southeast Asian
Foreign ministers are to hold a special
meeting about the violence in Myanmar
fantastic Felix next the young Montreal
are moving up the ranks in tennis
[Music]
becoming one of the best tennis players
on the planet is no easy feat and the
hard work and determination of Felix OJ
Elias seem is paying off the 22-year-old
Canadian has been on a roll recently
playing tournaments in Europe Mike
Armstrong looks at how fast his star is
rising and where he could be headed
whether or not that nickname sticks it's
earned Canadian Felix Jose aliasim is
wrapping up a month to remember
back-to-back tournament victories
Antwerp this past weekend and Florence
just seven days earlier you know these
kind of results inspire a nation the
head of tennis Canada is basically
beaming Michael Downey saysim has every
tool needed to compete and succeed speed
strength and size and just 22 years old
the sky is the limit
his potential is number one in the world
and multiple Grand Slam championships
and he's probably more than capable with
Dennis to lead this country to multiple
Davis Cup titles like Felix is that good
now before any of that the next few
weeks are important if things continue
oji aliasim can qualify for the year-end
ATP finals only the top eight men over
the calendar year qualify with more than
20 million dollars in prize money up for
grabs
I need the water some players when
they're on the cusp and have something
like a carrot like that dangling might
be difficult for them to you know fight
off that pressure but for Felix it seems
like it's been the opposite that it's
really propelled him to play his best
over the course of these past two weeks
now one thing that makes this year
important for Oceania Sim is the monkey
he got off his back coming into 2022 his
career record in tournament finals was
oh for eight in fact tied for the worst
record of all time and he didn't even
win a set he was Owen 16 in sets well
this was the day that changed
won his first tournament in February he
celebrated with his father over Face
Time and a few tears he's not quite a
household name like Nadal or Djokovic
but he's very much now in the
conversation Mike Armstrong Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen Happy Diwali to
all of you who are celebrating today we
leave you tonight with some of the
Diwali celebrations in India the
five-day Hindu festival of lights is
celebrated by millions of people around
the world people in India are
celebrating together for the first time
in years now that public health
restrictions have been lifted thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]